Los Angeles operates the largest jail
system in the United States and in fact
some research shows that Los Angeles
operates the largest jail system in the world.
There's just tons of neighborhoods
where they're spending more than a
million dollars a year locking people up.
We generated a set of maps showing who
was being incarcerated in Los Angeles
and on what charges.  It can do so much
harm as it has done in my family.
You've taken resources out of
communities and put it into locking
people up. There's a strong community
intuition that a large number of people
are being arrested on drug possession
charges and DUIs. There's a mental issue
that's going on... addiction. We didn't know
that for sure so the only way was to
conduct a research project and that's
what we did with Million Dollar Hoods
So in LA we don't have a vertical city
we have ten million people living in a
giant strip mall because of that we
don't we can't really talk about million
dollar blocks.  How do we think of
ourselves living in communities here in
Los Angeles and we tend to think about
about neighborhoods about hoods.
So we have the race, arrest date, arrest locations that we're going to geocode
So all of this is data that, according to law, law enforcement
agencies must provide. About a year and a
half ago I began requesting this data
from the Los Angeles Police Department
and the Los Angeles Sheriff's Department
and I really had to fight and struggle
with them to get access to the data.
As you look through it states and the city are not aligned. You can't just geocode it as is
We'd have to literally one-by-one move... They're shifted.
How long do you estimate it would take to clean that all up. I want to say less than a month but...
It's unfortunate because the data we got is so dirty unless we want to pay thousands and thousands of
dollars to geoode all these addresses
then we're stuck with what we have.
Once we are able to successfully geocode these addresses it allows us to
do a now spatial representation of those home addresses.
And see the discrepancies between cost and
incarceration and neighborhoods right. I
think it's the most important data we
have yeah with the cost and the charges
because it's the two together that show
you how much we're spending on incarcerating
people for addiction related and mental
health related issues. The types of
charges that people are being picked up
for tend to be those that if you are
impoverished or precariously housed
underemployed that you're more
vulnerable for arrest because you are
engaging in these kinds of activities
in public rather than doing it inside of
your home. People gonna do what they do.
The way the police police our community is different.
This is Jody Lane and Avenue
O. What happened to me on the night that
I was pulled over
I stopped immediately... came up to my car
banged on my window extremely hard. He
started to arrest me immediately and he
kneed me and he ran in towards me and
pepper sprayed me I took a DUI test on
the field I passed it. I was found not
guilty I honestly think that I would
have got shot and killed that night if I
was intoxicated.
OK so for those of you who do have it...
We're trying to not just bring this data like as a mapping
platform to other people
but really to educate the population that's being
affected by it. What we did is we began
holding a series of what we call rebel
mapping workshops where we're teaching
skills to youth.
Many of the young men in my family have
been impacted by incarceration. They
separated and fell into different types
of things like addiction. It led into a
lot of other issues where you know we
didn't know how to help. It's really a
kind of a source of pride for us in the
sandbox crew to not just be you know
armchair researchers.
So what Million Dollar Hoods teaches us is
that millions of dollars are being spent
every year on incarceration in just a
few neighborhoods and what it helps us
to do is to begin to imagine new ways
that we can spend that money.
Jobs and youth centers and healthy
environments and healthy healthy
communities that's part of a public
safety strategy. You know name it, we
don't have it here why is it? Why is it?
Historically it has always been racially
marginalized communities and
impoverished communities that have
experienced a disproportionate share of
policing here what these Million Dollar
Hoods maps show is that little has
changed in Los Angeles we are still
disproportionately targeting communities
of color and working-class communities
with our policing and incarceration
resources.